[Music]
hi
mystery recap here today i am going to
explain an american science fiction
disaster film called geostorm
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 2019 when climate change has peaked
at its highest the world isn't what it
used to be because of the changes in
ocean pattern rise in surface
temperature and melting polar ice
different parts of the world suffer
different natural calamities like
tsunamis floods droughts volcanic
eruptions earthquakes anti-vax rallies
typhoons and so on cities and countries
are destroyed within seconds the east
river swallows lower manhattan and a
heat wave kills two million people at
once in madrid in such conditions it is
clear that no single country can solve
the problem on its own so the whole
world comes together as one to fight
nature the united nations funds a
singular project with the top scientists
of the world to create a satellite
called dutch boy the scientists work
tirelessly not as representatives of
their nations but of humanity after all
the hard work they finally find a way to
neutralize the storms with a web of
thousands of satellites connected to the
dutch boy satellite the satellites are
meant to deploy countermeasures in
specific parts of the world the
countermeasures impact the basic
elements of the weather and neutralize
it as needed in the area the project is
overseen by scientists from the
international space station the mission
is successful and the situation of the
world changes within days the dutch boy
is programmed and designed by chief
architect jake lawson he also leads the
group of scientists and is the main
reason the mission was successful after
the chaos settles a problem arises when
the u.s government tries to take over
the dutch boy claiming it as their own
for this they will have to get
permission from jake however jake
believes that the project doesn't belong
to a singular country hence despite
being an american he doesn't accept the
offer because of this the officials fire
him from his post and employ his younger
brother max instead max had known about
the official's plan to fire jake and
even helped them with it jake leaves the
office in anger vowing to never forgive
max
the scene then cuts to three years later
all this time the dutch boy has worked
its best and has stabilized the earth's
weather however one day the u.s army in
afghanistan finds a tribe in the middle
of the desert to their utmost surprise
the otherwise hot place is freezing it
looks as if a cold frost has frozen the
specific area and its people within
seconds the situation is immediately
reported to the u.s government and a
meeting is held to discuss the matter
outside the meeting hall max meets his
fiance sarah wilson who is also a us
secret service agent at the meeting the
president and secretaries declare that a
malfunction in the afghan satellite
linked to the dutch boy was the reason
for the cold frost instead of taking
responsibility they discuss how they can
keep the incident secret so they won't
be criticized this enrages max who
actually cares for people's lives he
proposes to send an engineer to the
international space station who can
report the problem to the us that way
they can make sure it won't happen again
in the future the u.s secretary of state
leonard deckham asks max to appoint jake
on the matter because he is the only one
who knows the dutch boy like the back of
his hand max is a little skeptical of
the idea but goes to meet jake
immediately meanwhile in the space
station the scientists and astronauts
replace the afghan satellite one
astronaut is appointed to collect all
the data from the old satellite and
check it to see what is the problem with
it he collects the data from the
satellite in a hard drive and hides it
almost as if someone has ordered him to
do so right after he enters an airlock
and is trapped inside the windows break
and he is sent flying into space for the
past three years jake has been living in
florida where his daughter hannah visits
him every weekend max arrives at his
house and meets hannah she informs him
that jake has been making different
kinds of machines because his love for
engineering never lessened even after
being fired max then meets jake who
isn't happy about him visiting hannah
max tells him that dutch boy is
malfunctioning but jake confidently
claims it is not possible because his
creation is flawless he is apprehensive
of the situation but agrees to return to
the space station and check what caused
the malfunction cut to the climate
council headquarters in hong kong china
a supervisor from the dutch boy program
chang long is in his office working as
usual the temperature is extremely hot
so cheng goes to a nearby grocery store
and gets some water and eggs everyone
knows eggs will cool you down as he
returns he accidentally drops the eggs
on the road and sees them being cooked
because of the temperature before he can
react an earthquake hits and the ground
starts spewing hot lava people panic and
run around trying to save their lives
chang quickly gets in his car and drives
away as the road behind him cracks open
soon the skyscrapers topple over and the
city is destroyed chang somehow manages
to save himself after reaching a bridge
with a lower temperature somewhere else
jake sets off for the international
space station for the first time in
three years the chief scientist and the
commander of the station ut fastbinder
welcomes him and introduces him to the
rest of the crew back on earth chang
calls max and informs him that he cannot
log into china's dutch boy database he
believes that someone is trying to keep
them from accessing the real reason why
the temperature rose that suddenly max
tries to log in but even his access is
denied confirming that their database
has been hacked chang then reveals that
if dutch boy has an overall system
failure a geostorm will rise on earth it
will be far worse than the extreme
weather conditions they were trying to
prevent as catastrophic weather events
will be triggered all over the globe all
at once a geostorm could potentially end
humanity and destroy the earth for good
right after the call a group of foreign
men with guns enter chang's office chang
manages to hide in time and save his
life the men take his laptop and all the
data he had about the dutch boy
malfunction the following day max asks a
cyber security expert dana to check what
is wrong with the database she
immediately finds out that someone has
hacked into the mainframe and is
deleting weather information back on the
space station jake and his team go
through the video footage of the airlock
malfunction and find out a drive had
stuck to the communication tower at the
time of the accident
jake and ute spacewalk and retrieve the
drive successfully however jack doesn't
trust the crew and lies to them saying
that they lost the drive in space he and
ute secretly go through the database and
find out that the satellites were
programmed to malfunction over hong kong
and afghanistan but they are not able to
find out who did it and why
my money's on thanos
at the same time chang flies to the u.s
to meet max and tell him everything he
heard from the people who barged into
his office but before chang can get to
him a stranger pushes him into a running
car max runs to his friend who is on the
verge of death before passing away chang
tells max something about a project
named zeus after that max is informed
about the situation at the space station
from jake who believes that someone from
the highest level of government is in on
the satellite malfunctions max takes
this information to dana and the two
search for a project named zeus in the
mainframe they find out that someone is
weaponizing dutch boy to attack specific
cities it has to be some higher official
who has access to the mainframe but they
do not know who
jake believes that someone has
programmed a virus in the dutch boys
system through which they can control it
the only way to stop this is to reboot
dutch boy so the virus can be destroyed
but for that they will need the
president's credentials and they are not
in a position to trust him the brothers
now suspect the president to be the one
behind all of this according to jake he
is using dutch boy to destroy the us's
enemy nations max gets to work on
acquiring the president's credentials to
stop the geostorm from occurring however
among the chaos jake is reported to of
200 satellite malfunctions an aggressive
hail storm in japan kills hundreds the
temperature in brazil drops freezing the
oceans and people on beaches the
international space station is altered
of a geostorm that will arrive in one
and a half hours soon the space station
initiates a self-destruction protocol
jake and his team had first programmed
this protocol to destroy the space
station in case it fell to earth now
every scientist has to leave the station
and fly back to save their lives
just then jake figures out that one of
his teammates duncan is responsible for
putting the virus into the dutch boys
system the two get into a fight which
ends when duncan gets sucked into space
because of a broken window back on earth
max is at a presidential speech when the
secretary of state leonard asks him what
is wrong max tells him everything about
the president using the dutch boy as a
weapon leonard asks him more about
project zeus but max realizes he never
told him about the project it is then
revealed leonard is the one behind the
malfunctions all this time he wants to
take the president's position by blaming
the dutch boy malfunction on the current
president as soon as max realizes this
leonard tries to kill him but the man
saves himself and gets to agent sarah
the two plan to kidnap the president and
take his biometrics which will reboot
the dutch boy and save the planet sarah
deliberately causes a shootout making
the guards take the president away for
his safety she then knocks one of them
out and takes the president to a car
with max the couple explains everything
to him in the car while they are being
chased by leonard's men meanwhile
several massive tornadoes hit mumbai
while a heat wave hits russia killing
hundreds of people in the space station
all of the crew gets into a shuttle to
return to earth but jake and yute stay
behind because someone has to manually
reboot the program after max acquires
the president's biometrics in the
following scene max and sarah
successfully get leonard arrested he is
still not regretful for killing so many
people for his personal gains
after he is arrested they bring the
president to the mission control
headquarters there the president
provides his biometrics and thanks jake
for his sacrifice on a video call max
realizes that his brother is going to
die and apologizes for sending him there
in the first place at last jake asks him
to take care of his daughter and hurries
to reboot the satellite with only a few
seconds left until the geostorm he and
ute successfully reboot the system and
all the natural calamities in the world
die down within seconds the world is
finally saved but jake and ute are now
in the space station that is about to
self-destruct to save themselves they
get into an old satellite that launches
into space without a destination the two
watch the space station explode into
pieces while flying away fortunately one
of the scientists from the mission
control notices their satellite and
sends a shuttle to get the two the
shuttle finally attaches to the
satellite and returns to the earth
saving everyone cut to six months later
jake has been reappointed to manage the
newly built space station he and max
have a good relationship now both as
brothers and co-workers the movie ends
as jake's daughter hannah narrates that
as long as humans remember we share one
future we will survive
remember everyone the climate crisis is
a real thing but if we can all just work
together gerard butler will save us all
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching